that's why life sound sounds awesome  right and it is the twilight zone is  essentially an area that's below the  limits of normal recreational scuba  diving technology but above where you  would send an ROV or submersible of some  sort and so there's this narrow band a  sort of 200 to 500 feet that's totally  unexplored half of what we see down  there is unknown to science and we want  to be able to study those animals we had  to we've developed that technology and  that the skill within the academy in  order to be able to do exploration  diving in that region  [Music]  now there's this still these unexplored  regions on earth that you know we know  more about the surface of the Moon than  we do about what's underneath the ocean  and I think that's tremendously  inspiring for people to see you know  look there's still so much more work to  be done now and the depths of the ocean  [Music]